Selam aleykum guys and welcome to
another episode of solemnity
today we're in Accra in Ghana and this
is the DNR Turkish restaurant take a
look inside
inside the menu there's a lot of salad
on the menu
Vanessa's having some
also on this menus is a lot of images
every single meal has a different image
on it
look like so you're about to try Turkish
item this is probably one of my favorite
drinks this is like let's see a we call
this listening
in trouble
are you meant to be know if you Turkish
this is meant to be seen look at that
oh yeah wait off in that show you
something
okay so what time did you order your
food
exactly no no no that didn't go here
just he left the mini ago so what time
is it now okay good
why what's at 714 okay so
somebody some some some intelligence has
told us now you guys had a special time
in Iraq don't worry about that what
happened in Iraq we know what happened
in Iraq stays in Iraq but can you share
your experience god
[Music]
fine tonight can you can you tell it can
you tell us can you can you tell us what
happened is that every second how did it
Hank so one of the many places around
the world this Mosul in Iraq was my
sister
deployed two also to do a water project
with UNICEF
I need to take Monta the most
five liters of water every single day
this boat I would both enter the city of
Mosul while there was a walk away
we take bottle every day now one day
while you away we basically got
surrounded by some ass women so they
many big ones
they stopped our college they were
basically he wanted us together
military checkpoint technical stuff
someone came riding on a bike remember
that some banking right here on the bike
something about this place
get behind the building throwing stones
rooms we thought this was like a play
office acting guys people are cousins to
get the hell out with us rooms are
coming
this
visualize what all those big uns their
bounty hunters
just even themselves
just waiting in the car helicopter you
can hear it but you can't see us all I
have reviews like like that's all sound
and at that point I'm a Germanic we got
one guy
everybody get in the car he was another
guy saying don't wait in the car to be
in the car that's always come to talk
same way in the guy working with you
know
kidnap us or take us or whatever they
turned around and they start shooting
because these prices right now shooting
at them so in the middle of a good
battle between these two groups and
we're just taking cover
and then our no II just
600 meters so we're going to conjugate
the suck in my mind is literally about
200 meters
with
as we were
and there was a woman in Washington
tonight with three kids played in the
street like his normal life is nothing
but with this I was on the pool the
ground was shaking shaking shaking and
it's got to be like the scariest
scuse me
to run away from that literally when
everybody starts shooting hmm
but looking around us and everybody
except is still living no my life is
that I walk into the streets
keeps up named Mikey said someone's
wearing a washing help it's absolutely
crazy so we got us because according to
a military checkpoint
like they the deficit they gave us on
security and system of the day in
Roxbury
we're never stopped
computer three things like salad chili
sauce
Bucci be
24 minutes past 7:00 sore tomorrow
seven minutes
since we older than the stars have come
the real test is home to be to think
because how is I use this in my vision
hours almost typically very corner
ypg
knees Oh what does it say on your
t-shirt since you talked about it up
[Music]
this is actually helpful position of
people in the streets a little bit
which is I think that we need whatever
way that engages people prove to them
the misconception is tomorrow
just finished up food we're gonna be
cool
a 10-point checklist to rate this
restaurant that was given if you check
the link below in this video well here
in front of my building educational
facilities most schools and all these
people personally I wanna say
not quality quality of I think was
amazing with everything else that's in
this area of the food here competitor uh
competitive even competitor here is
quality after the ballast is really our
core fibers right especially we have to
take into consideration
there's no other food like this in this
area whatsoever
so for me
citrus
serving sentences of
good intentions an athlete another thing
to take into consideration is we know
that the character of the people and
everything
everything is when we must have order we
have to ask three or four times and it's
not like the guy was busy doing anything
and it is very late and I think about
this point sorry I say I say
magistration
but yeah I think three space retention
time
very good because we ordered our food
the starters
so 10 minutes after that starters yeah
11 minutes was enough time for sure how
fast autist
you know sometimes we have these torches
we sit around for the things that happen
to us perfect
portion and price - price lost now okay
oh [ __ ]
and look at my plane
which is a good thing because it means
it's um food is get wasted but I think
also because of the hummus of the Stata
that's probably I didn't finish the
paint a white kebabs they I specifically
told the guy I don't want the bread
pieces on today the breadcrumbs are they
anyway
bring the bread forgive me anyways
they're gonna do swings was up yes he
was happy to waste our food and I had to
start it and even a stopped in this
difference one axis to the ages
with a proportion sexy feet as you can
write this universal
Lexy
a good sized portion as we gonna
remember we don't need much on our onion
movie we have the other day we ate that
two o'clock seven something now
all right so with this one we'll do it
we rate it from somebody that's coming
so coming from Korean is not so much I
couldn't get a fight I when you go to
enter key system in the UK just your
means is the first attempt on average so
come in from the UK shall sales force
man
CDs or less than 10 CDs and they'd have
to make they move east in it NZ suddenly
could not why - yes
they could apply buy me another daily
salary so for the locals from here to
every day we get to the doctor body and
how things are we go to who
to
different for funding the president I
guess the protection living area
it's okay Allah knows best
is the menu alone Lana one second why
did you do that with your fingers were
seam allowances how it you dictionary
yes okay heroin is the menu
now that's down to how
yes Leslie muzic yes
new boy do they have howdy-howdy no a
console album but you know we're
insecure do they have a segregated area
everybody's together in what they do
together forever what you have
my student area I have to take into
consideration
and finally do they have yes they do
have a prayer we've used their already
balance I think they've got very very
good quality food
here in Ghana
in review anymore
your message of the comment section
below and also don't forget to use the
link below to donate towards the
education complex the news and the water
projects out here with the stem
initiative learning and human relief
foundation